welcome back okay we're talking about
Koopman operator theory why it's useful
for representing nonlinear systems how
you get those representations from data
how you could use those coordinate
transforms for optimal non-linear
control and we've been talking about
kind of what we want to do where it's
going what's hard now and what's you
know what we want to do in the future
and one of the challenges kind of an
essential challenge of modern
data-driven dynamical systems is
handling multi scale physics okay so
assistance with with multiple scales and
space and time very very important to be
able to do this especially with Koopman
operator theory so this is work with
kathleen champion who's working with
nathan cuts and myself on applying these
data-driven methods to multi scale
systems in time and so this is a really
nice use of this Hankel alternative view
of Koopman this kind of time delay
Koopman for multi scale dynamical
systems so she's looked at a number of
systems Vanderpol lawrence Rossler here
these are just single oscillators chosen
parameter values to be quasi periodic
and it turns out that time delay
coordinates and doing DMD dynamic mode
decomposition on time delay coordinates
gives you nearly perfect closed linear
models that capture these kind of
nonlinear essential non-linear dynamics
and Kathleen has since gone on to show
you can use these delay coordinates for
multi scale systems where you have vast
scale separation fast dynamics and slow
dynamics okay so essentially if you
increase the rank of your model of your
havoc model if you increase the kind of
how many eigen time delays you use you
get closer and closer and closer to this
nonlinear van der Pol oscillator and
also the the longer or shorter the
delays you use the closer you get to
these pure-tone sine waves which are
kind of these Koopman embeddings okay
and then like I said she's also applied
this to systems that have a very
different separation of time scale so I
have one
kind of Vanderpol oscillator that's slow
another Vanderpol oscillator that's fast
and they're coupled and essentially what
she's doing in these data-driven Koopman
based methods to pull out to tease out
the timescale separated dynamics from
measurement data so from limited
measurement data in this case she's not
measuring everything she just has x1
plus x2 okay so this is definitely a
step towards moving Koopman methods
towards multi scale systems
Nathan Cutts has also written a paper
called multi resolution DMD where
essentially he uses this multi
resolution in time idea to pull out
these intermittent phenomena like El
Nino modes in the global sea surface
temperature and things like that so you
know very interested in moving towards
multi scale systems with these Koopman
and data Durbin methods this is a very
nice example moving in that direction so
I encourage you to read this paper so
essentially we've been looking at all of
these these topics right when we don't
know equations we try to build these
regression models from data that's what
dynamic mode decomposition extended DMD
sparse Koopman eigenfunction
identification and deep neural nets all
do that when you don't have equations
and they all try to find these
coordinate transformations that map my
nonlinear system into a linear
representation we can use those linear
representations for optimal nonlinear
control so essentially finding those
good coordinate systems is one is a
one-time expensive upfront cost training
that huge neural network or building
those delay coordinates but once I have
that representation I can do optimal
non-linear control much more effectively
using simple linear analysis and then
we've also talked about how to extend
these methods for kind of these extra
difficult problems like chaotic
transient non stationary intermittent
phenomena and multi scale physics okay
and of course this is you know not
complete this is not a complete story
there's so much more to do we need to
tie these together we need to scale
these two much larger systems we need to
figure out where it works and where it
doesn't how fast it is is that upfront
cost
worth what we benefit from downstream
but at least we see that Koopman can
potentially help affect solutions and
all of these major major problems of
modern dynamical systems
ok so we're excited to see where this
goes you know excited to have all of you
working on this and interested in these
problems because this is really a key
enabling technology for the future
taking massive amounts of data and
getting interpretable and effective
coordinate system representations where
those dynamics look linear so that you
can really do powerful things like
nonlinear estimation and prediction and
control okay thank you